hello there guys and welcome to another
video regarding the obi-wan kenobi tv
series and in this video we have some
actually really exciting news we're
talking flashbacks with anakin and
obi-wan
an actress being casted for leia
inquisitors from star wars rebels
and more so you know what let's just get
straight into it so this information
comes from jordan mason
so this is you know rumors i would like
to get that out of the way this is a
rumor
however he has a really good track
record for being correct
i would say this could be the real deal
but yeah just take it with a grain of
salt anyway
with that out of the way let's get into
it so it reads here it was reported that
they're going to do
cast in for both young luke and leia i
can tell you leia is a part of kenobi in
a big way
in fact from what i've heard the stuff
dealing with leia is pretty much the
reason for the whole show and what gets
obi-wan into another adventure
even better i can tell you that vivian
blair actress from bird box and we can
be heroes has been cast in the role
so if this is true it seems like leia
instead of luke is going to be
i'm a big part of the show i remember
reading information about the show that
obi-wan was going to go on an adventure
off
planet off world and like hold on how
are they going to do that like i'm
defeated purpose because you know he was
meant to look after luke
on tatooine so why is it leaving the
planet but this
this is a good reason you know he's
going off planet because of leia which
is another skywalker
why is he going off planet for leia we
don't know there could be so many
different reasons why
but i would say she's probably
threatened in a way her life is at stake
so everyone has no choice but to leave
planet to save her
and for luke we got no clue what actor
there is for him but
i guess we'll find out sometime soon
anyway let's continue through the
article it says here
as for other roles i've heard that we'll
be seeing a few characters who
initially appeared in star wars rebels
the show itself said about nine to ten
years before the rents of that show
it makes sense that we'll see plenty of
those characters pop up which brings me
to the actor
sung kang from what i've heard sun kang
has played one of the inquisitors
in fact during an interview kang made
mention of seeing vader and said and
referenced being put into a star wars
costume both of my sources seemed
pretty confident when they said kang was
playing none other than the fifth
brother
also in the interview kang city saw
multiple jedi walking around on set
so potentially we could see a fight with
inquisitors against jedi
who knows maybe there's a flashback
sequence where the inquisitors are
hunting down the jedi that would be
pretty sick why when a topic of
inquisitor's article says
others have heard slash reported that
there seems to be quite a few
inquisitors including
another we've seen before referring to
rebels and yes there'll be plenty of
clone wars flashbacks that feature
a certain apprentice obviously referring
to anakin skywalker now this is the one
thing that i've really really wanted to
see from the show is flashbacks of
obi-wan and anakin
in the clone wars or just potentially
their jewel on mustafar with
obi-wan being haunted seeing anakin you
know burning in the lava and stuff i
feel like this show has
a lot of emotional potential and you
know it looks like they're going to
utilize that and i hope they do so i
couldn't be more excited for the show
it's definitely to show that i'm most
excited
for out of any of the star wars shows
and the good news with that is
apparently this show is on track to land
in spring
2022. to be honest i was thinking the
show was going to release at the end of
2022
so releases in spring instead then you
know i'll be stoked
anyway that's about it for this video a
lot of interesting new information
that's been released
again it's just a rumor but the track
record from this guy is
uh very good he seems to get most things
right so i
am confident that we'll see at least a
couple of these things come true if not
all of them without
the way guys make sure to like and
subscribe and leave a comment down below
if you're excited for the kenobi show
and what do you want to see from this
show
[Music]
you